Um,
for those who are very creative but high in neuroticism,
how should one work to gain emotional stability in order to go out into chaos to
do more creative things?
That's a really good question.
You know what I learned about that by reading Young's works on Alchemy,
weirdly enough.
And so back again in graduate school when I was writing starting to write maps
of meaning and really tearing myself apart psychologically,
I'm trying to understand evil I suppose the evil of the Cold War and the evil of
the individuals who compose Nazi Germany and Stelling this Brusha.
Um,
uh,
I was reading Carl Jung because he,
he,
he wrote his tracks on alchemy where a lot about self transformation and he
talked about,
uh,
it's hard to explain his works on Alchemy,
but suffice it to say that his advice was something like,
the advice he derived from the alchemist was that if you are going to make mess
around with very complicated and dangerous matters,
that's a good way of putting it.
That you should really put your life together.
And so I would say the right way to deal with your neuroticism is to increase
your conscientiousness.
Because we also know that the higher your conscientiousness,
the lower your neuroticism conscientiousness does seem to keep neuroticism and
check.
And so I would say,
and have said this to many people,
um,
clean your room,
organize your life,
like get a routine,
get up everyday at the same time,
go to bed at the same time.
Establish discipline habits.
And that will help a lot.
Schedule like,
and here's how to use a schedule.
Use it.
Use a calendar.